الضفه الغربيه حيث قتلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فجر اليوم بالرصاص الشابين
فؤاد عابد ومحمد حوشيه خلال اقتحامها بلده
كفردان غرب مدينه جنين بالضفه الغربيه
تابعه تطورات وردود الفعل من رام الله مع
مراسله الجزيره جيفارا البديري مده طويله
قضتها قوات الاحتلال في جنين واطلقت
الرصاص هل نحن امامنا صقر مختلف بعد تولي
الحكومه الجديده عما كانت عليه مثل هذه
الاحتجاجات الاقتحامات من قبل
بالفعل زين هو نفق مظلم الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي حتى لم تعقد بعد جلستها
الاولى والمتوقعه يوم غد تبدا همم رسائلها
الداخليه سواء للمستوطنين او الفلسطينيين
بهذه العمليه العسكريه التي استمرت على
مدار اكثر من عشر ساعات تخللها بتطبع قتل
الشابين همم محمد حوشيه وفؤاد عابد اللذين
تم تشييعهما انطلاقا من مخيم مدينه جنين
باتجاه مسقط راسيمهما في بلده اليامون
وكفر دان بعد ليله شهدت ايضا اشتباكات
مسلحه ولكن كان المشهد الاهم ايضا رغم
بركان الدم حسب وصف الفلسطينيين المتواصل
منذ بدايه العام الماضي هو همم مشهد
العقوبات الجماعيه حسب وصف المؤسسات
الدوليه حتى من بينها الامم المتحده وهو
نصف منازل فلسطينيه حيث تم نصف منزلي ذوي
الشهيدين همم عبد الرحمن واحمد عابد
اللذين كان متهمين بقتل ضابط اسرائيلي عند
حاجز الجلمه الشمالي جنين في سبتمبر ايلول
الماضي في هجوم مسلح ادى لمقتل هذا الضابط
الكبير في الجيش الاسرائيلي واضح ان هذه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وفي اليوم الثاني من
العام وبعد اقل من اخى اربعه ايام على
تسلمها ليزمام الامور وسده الحكم لن يكون
الامر بالهين هنا فقط انه نوضح شيء اخر
زين الانذار الان تتجه بعد جنين وايضا ما
كان قد تحدث الجمعه الماضيه في نابلس ولا
ثاني همم اصلا هم اصل المشهد على مدار
العام الماضي ولم تكن حكومه لبيد باقل عنف
مع الفلسطينيين
الانظار تتجه الان الى المسجد الاقصى
المبارك واعلان وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي
وهو الذي يعتبر الاكثر تطرفا اثمار بين
كبير نيته همم اقتحام المسجد الاقصى
المبارك يوم غد او بعد غد وهناك الان
اجتماعات تقيميه امنيه سياسيه اسرائيليه
لهذه الخطوه بن كثير كانوا يقتحم وايضا
نفس المسجد الاقصى ولكنه هذه المره سيدخل
ويتباهى بانه يدخل وزير للامن القومي هذا
هذا المنصب الذي تم فقد تعي- يعني تشكيله
ليناسب لكبير والذي اصبح بالطبع هو الان
المسؤول الفعلي عن الشرطه الاسرائيليه
التي كانت تنظم الامور اولى الانتقادات
لهذه الخطوه والتحذير منها جاء على لسان
المعارضه الاسرائيليه وتحديدا رئيس
الحكومه المنصرفه همم لبيد الذي قال ان
هذه همم ان وصف
بني كبير بانه جنه جنه ويكذب ويشوه وان
هذه الخطوه هي استفزاز سيعرض
المستوطنين تحديدا للخطر بمعنى في اشاره
الى الخشيه من عمليات فلسطينيه منفرده كما
قام بها على سبيل المثال عدي التميمي
وغيره من الشهداء الفلسطينيين الذين قاموا
بعمليات ضد مستوطنين وجنون الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وكان اثار الماضي هو قمه وذروه
هذه العمليات ولكن بالطبع ايضا القياده
الفلسطينيه تحذر امين سر اللجنه التنفيذيه
يقول ان هذا الامر وقح وهمم هو همم
قمه التحدي سافر والوقح حركه حماس بتطبع
حذرت برسائل شديده اللهجه وجهتها الى
الوسيط المصري اولا وايضا هناك رسائل من
القياده الفلسطينيه الى الاردن والى دول
عربيه بمنع بني كثير من الدخول الى المسجد
الاقصى المبارك لان ذلك سيعل المنطقه
باكملها ولكن بالطبع بين كبير مسلح باكثر
من مليون مستوطن كانوا ايضا عدد من قادتهم
صلوا الرسائل اللي بينكفير بانه يجب
اقتحام المسجد الاقصى المبارك باعتباره
حسب ما يزعمون بانه شبه الهيكل تباهى بني
كبير انه اصبح الان على نشرات الاخبار
الاسرائيليه الخبر الاول لان خطوته
باقتحام المسجد الاقصى تعني الكثير
للجماعات الاستيطانيه المتطرفه اذا الامور
تتسارع بشكل كبير جدا رغم انه كما ذكرت لك
زين لي لم لم تجلس هذه الحكومه حتى الان
على طاوله الحكم
ونتنياهو سيتراس هذه الجلسه يوم غد ما
الذي سيحدث خلال الايام القادمه الجميع
بانتظار ولكن في حاله غضب و التاهب على
كافه الاصعده سواء من الفصائل من الاهالي
من المواطنين من القيادات السياسيه همم
اتجاهات والاتصالات الدوليه مع كافه
الجهاز ولكن شيء اخي فقط زين نذكر هنا ان
همم ما قد يغير شيئا من الواقع ان نتنياهو
يوم الخميس الماضي عندما اعلن رسميا عن
تنصيبه رئيسا للحكومه الاسرائيليه ركز في
خطابي رغم تجاهل القضيه الفلسطينيه بانه
يريد توسيع رقعه التطبيع والسلام مع دول
عربيه واسلاميه كبيره نتنياه سيتوجه
الاسبوع القادم الى ابو ظبي العاصمه
الاماراتيه ولكن الان هناك المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هناك الاردن وبالتالي
كيف سيتصرف الثانيه وهذا ايضا امتحان لهذه
الحكومه التي كما ذكرنا حسب وصف الجميع هي
الاكثر تتطرف
جيفارا البديري من رام الله مراسله
الجزيره شكرا ج